Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here today.
And today I want to talk about what
is the hardest language to learn.
Now, if you enjoy my
videos, please subscribe.
You can click on the bell in
order to get notifications.
Uh, what's the hardest language to learn?
First of all, before I start, you may
notice there's some gaps in my library.
I've been going through culling
some of the books that I no
longer want to keep around.
So I've donated three boxes of
books to a local thrift store.
Anyway, that's why it looks
a bit messy back there.
Uh, the hardest language to learn,
you know, I think that's a very
difficult question because there are
so many factors that enter into that.
Um, you know, what do you
want to do with the language?
Uh, do you want to pass a test?
Uh, do you want to just
enjoy the language?
Do you want to enjoy movies,
books in the language?
Do you want to just be able to
communicate in the language.
And different languages are, you know,
they have different degrees of difficulty
depending on what you want to achieve.
But I would say that the biggest
factor in determining how difficult the
language is for you is how motivated
you are to learn that language.
If you find your motivation flagging,
if you find that you don't like the
language, that's going to make that
language very difficult to learn.
If on the other hand, you love
the language you want to...
learn the language,
you either you have a friend or a loved
one or a relative, or you enjoy aspects
of their culture and you're very motivated
that language will be easier to learn
because any objective difficulties only
make the language more interesting.
So you'll be, you know, pushing
yourself to overcome these difficulties.
So the number one consideration
in my mind is, you know, your
relationship to the language.
Second thing is how easy is it
to find content of interest?
Content that's comprehensible maybe,
but potentially even if it's not yet
comprehensible, if it's attractive
to you, and this is very subjective.
So here again, the, some people are
attracted by say anime for Japanese,
which doesn't appeal to me at all.
Uh, it can be anything.
I happen to be attracted to history.
So, uh, and, and right now I'm very
interested in the sort of central Asia,
uh, Iran and, you know, Turkish, Arabic,
even, uh, just finished reading a book
about, uh Genghis Khan and the Mongols and
the amazing impact they had on history,
both in a negative and a positive way.
Yeah.
So those kinds of things that, that, um,
you know, make it a, you know, in terms
of something you can sink your teeth into:
literature, history, music, whatever.
That's got to be there.
Uh, where you can't find that,
then it's more difficult.
And this can depend, this can vary
from, you know, time to time, you
may be trying to learn a language
and not find anything of interest.
And then later on, because you meet a
friend or because you discover a movie
or something, all of a sudden that
interest, then, you know, you're, you're
fired up again to learn the language.
And that's why it's so useful now
that in addition to whatever, you
know, beginner content you use.
You know, Assimil or Teach Yourself
or mini-stories at LingQ, uh, that,
that then you move on to things that
you can find on the internet and
which you can bring in to LingQ.
For example, whether it be off, uh,
you know, from YouTube or, or, or, uh,
eBooks, which I have often used, or,
uh, you know, a Netflix, uh, you have
to, you know, make it, you know, make
yourself, put yourself in a position
where you can access things that might
really, you know, turn your crank.
And there's the expression in French...
give yourself a chance to get
carried away by the language.
Don't go in with too many prejudices.
Saying this language is no good.
I don't like the sound of the language.
I find it boring.
Get in there, start to discover things
and pretty soon you may find that, uh, you
know, you will get attracted, uh, by it.
You know, I'm, I'm now going after
Persian and Arabic and Turkish, which
I wasn't particularly interested in
before and now I'm very interested in.
So that element of
motivation is very important.
Of course, you know, if we look at
objective considerations, Um, the more,
the language is similar to a language
you know, the easier it's going to be.
The more the vocabulary is similar,
particularly the vocabulary, so that you
don't have to struggle to remember words.
And I always say that the number of
words you know, uh, your, the size
of your vocabulary will determine
your ability to understand.
If you can understand well, you'll
eventually learn to speak well,
uh, or at least to communicate.
So, uh, how similar the language is to a
language you already know is a big factor.
This can have pluses and minuses.
Now I'm finding, for example, in
Portuguese, that I know Spanish, therefore
Portuguese, uh, from one perspective
is easier because the vocabulary
is like more than 90%, the same.
And the grammatical structure is
more than 90% the same, but because
they're so similar, it's difficult
to totally throw myself into
sort of a Portuguese environment.
The Spanish control center in my brain
is kind of holding on and preventing
me from, you know, totally starting
a fresh in this other language.
On the other hand, if I go into Arabic
or Persian, there is no other language
that is influencing my Persian or Arabic.
So to some degree, that is a difficulty
with languages that are very similar,
but that's a minor consideration.
Overwhelmingly the more similar
the languages are, the easier
it's going to be to learn them.
Another consideration of
course, is the writing system.
Uh, I've grown up reading,
using the Latin alphabet.
So even though I can read the
Cyrillic alphabet, I can read Chinese
characters, hangul, kanna, even
Greek, Arabic with some difficulty,
you know, it's so difficult.
I find to get used to comfortably reading
in another script it's one thing to
decipher it, figure out this is, these
are the symbols, this is what they, you
know, the sounds that they represent.
But to actually get there where you
can just comfortably read in another
script, I find that's a big step.
Like for me, Polish and Czech are
much easier than Russian and Ukrainian
because it's so much easier for me.
There's no resistance when I
read in the Latin alphabet.
Whereas reading in Cyrillic, even though
I have read so much in Cyrillic, like
it's just that little bit more difficult.
So it's always a challenge.
And when I learn another language with
another script, I put a lot of effort
into just, just making sure I spend
enough time reading in that script because
that's going to improve my comprehension.
And that's why I, for the time being,
I've put Turkish on the back burner
and I'm focusing on Persian and Arabic
in order to get my brain more and more
used to reading in this other script.
And I know from experience that everything
in language learning, including reading
in another script is just a question of
time and enough exposure so that your
brain will gradually develop new habits.
But the emphasis is on
gradually and slowly.
There's no instant Eureka!
So a different writing system obviously
is an element of difficulty, in
particular a writing system like Chinese
characters where it's not phonetic.
It's not a matter of learning a finite
number of symbols, 20, 30, 40, 50 symbols.
You have to learn thousands of pictograms.
So that makes Chinese more difficult.
I've said before that there is a
compensation because so many of what
we would term words in English are
combinations of these pictograms.
So once you have them, you can then
easily, more easily, remember new words
that are combinations of these characters
that you have already learned, but
still it does make it more difficult.
Pronunciation can be an issue.
Uh, but to me, that's also a question
of time and, uh, you know, the
solution to many of these difficulties
is simply exposing yourself to the
language, listening enough, getting
the intonation of the language.
Speaking, without feeling
self-conscious about it.
Uh, and of course, grammar, I find that,
uh, you know, objectively speaking,
uh, Chinese and even Japanese and
Korean grammar are less complicated.
There are fewer little bits of
detail that you can easily get
wrong than say in Russian, Slavic
languages, German and so forth.
So the more details there are in the
language, the more things that change
like case endings change or conjugations,
the verb endings change, the more
of these things that are not so much
a question of logic of the language
-
but I mean, there is that logic,
but a logic that is hidden behind
a bunch of rules and tables - the
more of these things you have in a
language, the more difficult it is.
Especially to speak correctly.
Now, if your objective is to
understand the language, to be able
to communicate, connect with people
as is the case with me and most of
my languages, I'm not tremendously
concerned about how accurately I speak.
Of course, I want to speak more
accurately, but, but I can't
speak accurately in all of these
languages that I'm learning.
Uh, I want to speak more accurately
if I make a video in Arabic.
And I, you know, I, I say, uh,
that I, you know, ... instead
of ... like you've got to change
the beginning, the suffix, depending
on the person and stuff like that.
And I get it wrong some of the
time, right some of the time.
And I hear that and I notice it and
slowly, hopefully I improve, but
it doesn't, uh, in any way, detract
from my enjoyment of the language.
On the other hand, if your goal, if
you're working uh in Arabic or Russian
or whatever, and you're, uh, putting
out business correspondence or you're
at formal meetings and there's obviously
a, or you're going to write a test,
then there is a greater
need to be accurate.
So difficulty in terms of understanding
it is one thing, difficulty in terms of
being able to read it and listen to it
and enjoy movies is one thing, difficulty
in terms of being accurate and creating
a very positive impression because you
are essentially making very few mistakes,
that's another level of difficulty.
I think, uh, honestly, uh, you know,
in French, some people find French
difficult to understand because of
the way the words flow into each
other with the sort of liaison.
Uh, but another big obstacle
in French is the gender.
Gender is more obvious in Spanish.
Uh, you know, most words that end
in "o" masculine and most words
that end in "a" are feminine.
Spanish, fairly straightforward...
Italian.
French, not so.
And when I listen to our Canadian
politicians, uh, English-speaking
politicians who speak French and
some of them speak quite well.
And yet the gender is the thing
that trips them up because it's not
something that we have in English.
It's very difficult to develop new habits.
New grammatical habits.
It doesn't prevent them
from communicating.
And the similarity with people
learning English, uh, I often mention
that we have a colleague Russian who
speaks absolutely perfect English.
There isn't anything he can't
express or explain in English.
And yet to him, the articles remain
a problem because obviously it's not
something that is part of the sort of
language habits of Russian speakers, or
for that matter speakers of many other
languages that don't have articles.
Uh, there are languages with no articles,
languages with no gender, languages with
no, uh, with, uh, no singular or plural.
Um, yeah.
Um, languages, uh, have a different,
uh, different ways of expressing
essentially the same thoughts.
And we have to get used to them.
And, uh, some of them are a little
harder to, you know, develop
these new habits than in others.
So there you have it.
So I don't want to say that any particular
language is harder to learn, but I
rather want it to set out what I think
are some of the factors that determine
how difficult a language may be for you.
Okay.
That's all I want him
to say on that subject.
Bye for now.